see Al Gore is a genius he used his
position as vice president to push the
global warming narrative he got everyone
scared he got the government scared and
willing to fund the fight against global
warming and then what did he do he
started a hedge fund a hedge fund called
generation Investment Management wow
what a noble sounding cause as a hedge
fund that invests in what do you know
renewable technology and how did this
hedge fund work out for him well in 2017
he was now worth an estimated 200
million dollars that's because over the
past 10 years the total return on
investment for renewable energy has been
367 percent higher than fossil fuels
algor created the problem and he offered
the perfect solution on a silver platter
his hedge fund but it didn't end there
Al Gore made half of his 200 million
Fortune by selling a TV channel to a
company owned by the Qatari governments
Qatar is a gulf nation that makes nearly
all its wealth from oil fossil fuels
click the link in the pin comment to
watch our full documentary on this